welcome and thanks everyone for coming
this is a really exciting day for
Carnegie Mellon and I'm very glad to see
the level of enthusiasm that indicated
by all of your presences so my name is
Nathan urban I'm the interim provost at
Carnegie Mellon University and a member
of the biological sciences department in
the center for the neural basis of
cognition it's my pleasure today to
start things off by introducing Carnegie
Mellon's president dr. subra Suresh who
will begin the discussion lead off the
program today by talking about what's
happening here at Carnegie Mellon in
brain science and and why we're doing
this now so with that dr. Suresh
Wow it's quite quite a group here thank
you all for coming the road leading up
to this morning started about a year ago
when I first arrived on this campus
talking to faculty meeting leaders of
different centers department heads and
talking about their aspirations for what
we could do collectively not something
new but something that's based on years
and decades of very deep scholarship lot
of intellectual contributions uniqueness
in contributing to knowledge but equally
generating new knowledge and the
opportunities and potential for
synthesizing all of that to have a
significant impact on a global stage and
one of the areas that came repeatedly in
my conversations with faculty across
campus was the need to bring together
expertise that already exists
world-renowned expertise that can be
packaged and combined in new and unique
ways so that CMU's contributions can be
synergized with contributions from other
institutions but equally rather than
solely relying on either federal support
our one source of support try to have a
public-private partnership on a global
scale and I knew quite a bit about
Carnegie Mellon strengths but I was just
pleasantly stunned and amazed at the
level of expertise that existed on this
campus and equally the level of
enthusiasm from various groups on campus
to bring this together we've had 20
years of expertise in the in the area of
neural basis for cognition combined with
engineering computer science psychology
philosophy policy and various other
activities across campus including by
chemistry etc bringing all of that
together in a new and unique way was the
aspiration of the faculty so I didn't
have to convince anybody but they push
me and in the first year I had a lot of
things to do and I was very happy to be
pushed in this direction because this is
an institution that has the what I would
call the intellectual horsepower to
contribute in a significant way and I'm
really delighted that through a lot of
hard work from a lot of people we are
here today I am equally grateful that
dr. Tom Insel director of the National
Institute for mental health is here
joining and I've known Tom from my
Washington time but he is one of the
leading voices for the brain initiative
across the country and for the u.s.
around the globe I am really delighted
that he is able to join us why CMU why
now and why the brain initiated so
between what I'm going to say and what
nathan is going to say next hopefully we
will address all of this and the faculty
have already shown responses to those
questions let's look at the global cost
economic cost let's start with just the
u.s. first the cost of addiction to
different substances and alcoholism to
the US economy every year is north of
half a trillion dollars or five hundred
and twenty four billion dollars mental
illness depression schizophrenia caused
an estimated 350 billion dollars to the
US economy Alzheimer's 215 billion
dollars Parkinson's 11 billion dollars
so 1.1 trillion dollar estimated cost
especially with the baby boomers going
into retirement an aging population
this is a significant national issue
significant economic issue for our
country globally it's five trillion
dollars aging population in china in
japan europe etc so that's the economic
cost of diseases associated with the
brain human costs if you are lucky
enough to reach the age of 85 you have a
one in two chance fifty percent
probability of developing Alzheimer's by
the time you reach age 85 1 in 68
children in the US are diagnosed with
autism spectrum disorder 16 million
Americans every year are known to
experience major depression every 20
seconds or per minute three people in
the world commit suicide Lord of that
happens in heavily populated countries
such as China and India but three per
minute every 20 seconds a fellow human
being takes his or her own life so
that's the human cost of diseases or
symptoms associated with a human brain
let's just take one area alcohol abuse
and addiction it's known to be the fifth
leading risk factor for premature death
and disability globally it's number one
cause a risk factor for people in the
age group of 15 to 49 so these things
bring home the point of why this is so
why a leading research institutions such
as carnegie mellon should embark on
contributing to a global cause it all so
powerfully brings home the point
that while it's a local issue while it's
a national issue it's equally a global
issue 5 trillion dollars globally it
doesn't it not only involves the biology
of the human brain it very strongly
involves the psychology of the human
mind it also involves cultural factors
social factors your friends your family
who you associated with how they
influence your behavior and how that
influences and leading up to the human
costs that we talked about so it cannot
just be a local Pittsburgh if I effort
it cannot just be a u.s. effort if we
were to make progress we have to look at
all different angles from around the
globe and that's why right from the
beginning it was abundantly clear to us
starting going back to last summer that
any effort or any initiative we try to
create cannot be just a narrowly focused
effort and it has to have a global
perspective a global reach and a global
involvement in a sustained way so what
do we need what is needed now there are
many many things we need now because the
US National Academy of Engineering in
2004 issued a report of the 14 grand
challenges facing humanity in the 21st
century one of the major Grand
Challenges among the list of 14 that the
National Academies experts recommended
that we address as a human race in this
century is because it's the National
Academy of Engineering they called it
reverse engineering the human brain but
nevertheless it's studying and
understanding the human brain if it was
national academy of sciences or
institute of medicine will be called
something different but the point is the
same and so they call it reverse
engineering the human brain CMU as
Nathan will talk in greater detail is
uniquely positioned to address this from
certain angles where it has decades and
decades of expertise and
strength here are just four areas to
think about where we can uniquely
contribute to understanding about the
human brain and to develop new tools
methods and technologies that help
address this grand challenge new imaging
technologies for viewing the brain
imaging technologies also give big data
and analyzing the big data is is
something that CMU is uniquely qualified
to do developing techniques that eel
massive amounts of data making sense out
the out of the data extracting useful
knowledge out of their data and even
developing tools hardware and software
that can handle that volume of data
tools such as artificial intelligence
and machine learning that that help us
extract information from that massive
amounts of data which is the Third Point
refining machine learning and data
science to accelerate analysis of
massive amounts of data just in the
context of understanding the human brain
and of course CMU is very well known to
be a place where multidisciplinary
interactions and multidisciplinary
research takes place so leveraging
multidisciplinary advances in the study
of biology behavior psychology in our
philosophy department we have wonderful
group leading group in mathematical
logic bringing all of this expertise
from computer science to policy to
engineering to all parts of campus a
business commercialization all of this
is going to be so critical so this is
essentially the intellectual core of the
uniqueness of what see'em you can do to
address this this particular grand
challenge it has to be a global effort
so obviously this is just the beginning
we've had a long history of
collaboration with the University of
Pittsburgh and their medical school and
that will continue on strengthened in
the years to come
through this brain brain hub the the
initiative that we are launching today
which will also include CNBC and many
other activities on campus so university
of pittsburgh is of course a
long-standing local partner in this
effort along with the medical enterprise
in the local region but we thought it
was very important for the reasons that
i mentioned that we have strong
connections and collaborations and
sources of creating support for research
that are global so that we can address
problems that we cannot address just in
pittsburgh alone so we for the last
couple of years we have a strong
collaboration with sun yat-sen
university in the gwangju province in
southern china about two hours driving
distance from hong kong and this past
summer when I met with President jus of
San Jackson University we talked about
this brain initiative and the
vice-president of their medical school
or Dean of the Medical School dr. Meng
feng li who happens to have an MD and a
PhD from University of Pittsburgh who's
here joining us today will be on the
panel they were very enthusiastic and
they are one of our partners Indian
Institute of Science in Bangalore is a
leading research university between
China and India they currently
constitute one third of the world
population and China India especially a
young population and India's population
will surpass China's population in about
10 years or so so that brings a
demographic concentration and a
connection and a research flavor and
data to the CMU brain initiative in new
and unique ways we were also very
fortunate to have a major philanthropist
in India who is also here joining us
today dr. Kris Gopalakrishnan and Chris
is one of the six Chris's over here
chris is one of the seven co-founders of
Infosys one of the largest IT firms in
the world and
is being affiliated with the firm for 33
years each of the cofounders of Infosys
including Chris are not only pioneers in
IT they are also philanthropist both
through their company and individually
and Kris Gopalakrishnan just about four
months ago established a 40 million
dollar brain research center affiliated
with Indian Institute of Science in
Bangalore through his private
philanthropy it's one of the largest
brain science research centers in the
world especially through private
philanthropy that was joined by the tata
group in india which contributed about
10 to 12 million dollars to the same
effort so that effort is a significant
component of brain research in India
today and when Chris and I talked
earlier this year he he very much wanted
to connect CMU's initiative with what is
evolving at indian institute of science
in fact CMU will become the first very
first beneficiary of his international
philanthropy and chris is supporting
Carnegie Mellon brain hub to connect to
the activities that we it will evolve
that that will evolve in in Bangalore in
the years to come so we are very
thankful to Chris for his contributions
we also have collaborations from the
University of Warwick so we have dr.
Theo our visit is visiting here and dr.
Judith Klein and they are representing
University of Warwick which has unique
contributions to make in several area of
data sciences in particular bringing in
local expertise from the Midlands in the
UK and also the medical division of
Oxford University and the mathematical
and physical sciences division of oxford
university especially combining
engineering approach and clinical
approaches to understand the human brain
in the context of trauma and human
diseases and they will have a unique
partnership with CMU where they will
jointly fund postdocs they've already
started that funding process with CMU so
these for initial entities will become
our partners when we hope that there
will be other partners who will join us
locally we also been beneficiaries of
philanthropic support the Hillman
foundation we have had conversations
with them Bruce Crocker from the Hillman
foundation is here joining us today and
they have provided support and to launch
the administrative structure of this
brain hub and we very much look forward
to working with the Hillman foundation
we also have support for presidential
fellowships through the Dietrich
foundation and which will be used to
support graduate students will be
involved in this effort we have other
philanthropic support that we will
announce through the through the course
of the year plus significant federal
support on top of it we have support
from deans and department heads
distributed across campus in terms of
their commitments and aspirations to
hire new faculty members during the next
five years so our goal is that when we
launch the brain hub today the overall
volume of activity through a variety of
public/private federal
state and local support will be
approximately on the order of about 75
million dollars over a five-year period
this is just the beginning and with the
involvement of all the colleges and
schools with connections to learning and
the Simon initiative etc we hope that
this will become a campus-wide effort
leveraging enormous strength and I'm
very pleased to reach this point because
this was one of the major aspirations of
the faculty when I from the very first
day I landed on this campus and so i
will stop at this point and invite our
interim provost dr. nathan urban to come
back to the stage and talk about his
perspective we are very fortunate to
have Nathan in this particular role
because he's a very distinguished neuro
scientist himself and I want to express
my enormous thanks to him for the level
of commitment and effort that he has
shown to this effort along with people
in our psychology department campus
leaders such as dr. Michael tour was the
currently the head of the psychology
department Marlene Berman who currently
directs the Center for Brain and neural
basis for cognition and people like rob
gas from the statistics department who
have played a major role in various
conversations across across the campus
in the in this effort and nathan has put
in an enormous amount of time in this
you know the very short period of time
he has been in this current job so
Nathan thank
you
Thank You subra so I want to spend a few
minutes talking about what we intend
what we plan to do in the next five
years and beyond by bringing together
the resources and the the talent and the
expertise that exists here on campus and
also with our partners across the globe
but first I want to say a little bit
about how we got here so Carnegie Mellon
for decades has been known as a place
where with a tremendous amount of
expertise and leading the field in
cognitive science also in areas of
artificial intelligence nearly inventing
the area of artificial intelligence and
certainly having an incredibly strong
reputation throughout all of engineering
so building on these decades of
excellence about 20 years ago in
partnership with the University of
Pittsburgh we're almost exactly 20 years
ago i should say there is a 20th
anniversary of the CNBC that's coming up
20 years ago in part because of the
vision of the arcane mellon Foundation
and faculty who are here at University
of Pittsburgh and Carnegie Mellon at the
time was the creation of the Center for
the neural basis of cognition which is a
joint center between the two
universities to investigate these issues
broadly speaking the neural basis of
cognition this has this these efforts
have matured and expanded beyond the
original sort of borders of the these
domains and and also the fields have
changed and increasingly the field of
neuroscience brain science cognitive
science all are relying on new
technologies the application of
techniques for the exploitation of big
data and we want to recognize that now
through the creation and integration of
efforts across campus and across the
globe to apply these these new
approaches to the study of brain science
so recognizing all this and with Subarus
vision and energy and enthusiasm we've
begun to put together and really
launched this initiative what we in what
we hope will be a big way which will
result in Carnegie Mellon becoming a
major hub for brain research across the
globe in connecting with global partners
so the overall goals of this initiative
I've alluded to them already for quite
some time we were calling this
initiative internally brain computation
and behavior recognizing that an
important component of what we wanted to
do was to study the brain study
computation and study behavior and
fundamentally use computational
approaches to link our understanding of
the brain to our understanding of
behavior this also will involve the
development of new techniques and
technologies for measuring brain
activity whether that be at the cellular
level or at the whole brain level and
also for measuring and monitoring and
analyzing behavior which i think is a
nun not completely untapped area but but
a really frontier area the use of the
sort of modern technologies that we
carry in our pocket in the form of cell
phones also inexpensive sensor arrays to
monitor behavior in a deep and
sophisticated way so once we have these
new technologies and we have all this
data we have all these algorithms we
also think it's going to be very
important to aggregate and analyze these
massive data sets of brain and behavior
and the partnerships especially with
well with with all of the partners that
we've been talking to will will provide
us incredible access to some of these
data sources whether it be data sources
on autistic individuals at suny at sin
or individuals with Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's disease at ISC in Bangalore
so very important in all these aspects
is the development of new technologies
the application of new technologies that
have been used in other domains to brain
science and the development of new
technologies and ultimately we want this
effort to have impact across a variety
of areas including health but also
commercialization if you look at the
Human Genome Project one of the key
steps was to develop technologies that
then could be used to study the human
genome we see the development of
technologies and really the
commercialization of technologies as
another outcome this will also have
implications for policy for
understanding of learning or well poised
to do that through connections here at
CMU with the Simon initiative and all of
these areas I think will be
important areas of impact for this
initiative on campus where our goal is
to link many aspects of campus many
centers many schools many current
activities in in this sort of central
hub hence the name brain hub which will
be a mechanism for integrating
activities bringing people together and
also providing some of the resources
that are needed to move the field
forward so in concrete terms we're
hoping we the plan is to support
postdoctoral fellows for
interdisciplinary research for the
training of next generation of
researchers in neuroscience creating
mechanisms for seed grant funding to
facilitate collaborations both within
Carnegie Mellon and with our partner
institutions super already mentioned the
support of graduate students by
presidential fellowships we want to use
these mechanisms to facilitate
innovation and entrepreneurship in part
in collaboration with the center for
innovation entrepreneurship here at
carnegie mellon and in the course of
doing this the mechanisms for doing this
we will also engage our partners and our
local groups in organizing meeting
symposia workshops in order to discuss
how we can best position ourselves to be
at the forefront of the next wave of
brain science just a note here to talk
about some of these details there will
be a campus-wide town hall meeting next
week at 4pm the location is known but I
forget what it is I believe it's a
auditorium in tepper so we're even
involving temper too so so as super
mentioned this would not be possible
with a whole variety of commitments to
support from philanthropic organizations
these include organizations that have
directly supported this initiative and
also which have supported areas faculty
and research and brain science over the
last few years also direct and in-kind
support from our industry our partner
institutions commitments internally
commitments of presidential fellowships
support for facilities that are needed
to do this kind of research seed funds
in the form of procede grants and then
ongoing federal state and local support
so all of these our hope is to bring all
these efforts together to do something
collectively that we can't do
individually so that's what we imagine
what we envision will happen in the next
few years at Carnegie Mellon and what
the impact we hope we will have